hey youtubers its charlie thank you
everybody that so many questions on my
Game of Thrones Q&A that that was mostly
about cleganebowl but now most everyone
is talking about this me read John Snow
theory so I definitely added that to my
questions thank you to everyone that
would not stop bugging me about this if
there's big news or a big theory or
something that everyone's talking about
but you don't see me talking about it on
Twitter and Facebook usually it's just
because I'm exhausted or like I'm still
passed out like I'm still asleep
every once in a while I will see
something that I think is nonsense I'll
just ignore it but this is really about
us as a fandom like discussing what's
going on so whether it has merit or not
feel free to keep bugging me about any
like small Theory anything at all I
totally love it when you guys bug me
about stuff like this one of the biggest
reasons that new books or new TV shows
don't take off is because they're not
interesting to talk about if there isn't
some subset of the fandom obsessing
about some aspect of the story or the
characters it's just a clear indication
that it's not interesting so as long as
there's stuff to go crazy about for Game
of Thrones I feel like it's going to be
one of the most popular things around
just you wait even after George r Martin
writes the last book like the last line
of the last book people will still be
arguing about stuff or it's like when
you see those Karate Kid edits where
Daniel is the villain of the story who
keeps picking the fights with the Cobra
Kai kids all in good fun but here we go
on to questions just careful for
spoilers if you're not caught up with
the show yet so here we go
bastards ass with it being late in the
seasons do you think that we could ever
see Lady Stoneheart
so what you're saying is is is since
it's been a couple seasons since she's
supposed to have shown up in the
storyline maybe it'll be a better
explanation as to like why she looks so
decrepit a lot of people might not know
about Lady Stoneheart she's just a
really notable character that the show
has skipped over that's really big in
the books without getting into too great
detail they are laying some
circumstances that could indicate that
she is going to be on the show but that
would require an actress coming back
filming scenes outdoors which we haven't
seen yet so he is it's still a
possibility especially with some of the
other people that they've cast this
season in Brienne storyline but we
really can't say for sure until they're
completely done filming all their
outdoor scenes so if you are holding out
hope for Lady Stoneheart
all is not completely lost I mean I'm
not expecting her but that doesn't mean
that she's not coming next question who
you asks how come Littlefinger and Varys
never tried to kill
other back in King's Landing I think
probably because it would have caused
more problems than it would have solved
that's the thing when you're dealing
with slippery people like Littlefinger
and Varys like they both have their
agendas completely independent of one
another I think that they each sense
that the other person has something of
value to offer them so it's more of a
keep your enemies closer situation next
question Steve M asks if the Hound comes
back who would be the one to revive him
and if everyone changes when they get
resurrected could he become a good guy
well well the thing about the the Hound
not being dead theory like all the
theories related to that state that he
did not die in the salt pans whenever
arya left him now in the books like the
encounter that he has is it was with
completely different people in a
different place but it's the same
situation arya just walks away she just
says peace I'm out of here and walks off
and doesn't know what ends up happening
to him she probably assumed that he's
dead but all the theories state that he
did not die he survived that encounter
in the books and on the show so any
personality change that he goes through
would be like a conscious process it
wouldn't be a side-effect of
Resurrection like he wouldn't lose a
piece of his soul all the pieces of the
soul that the Hound has lost so far had
been metaphorical like just terrible
things that he's done just chipping away
at him it would be cool to see him get a
Redemption arc but I kind of like the
version of the out I feel like
that's what makes him so much fun next
question McKee access considering the
Hound and Brienne fight didn't happen in
the books do you think if the Hound is
the gravedigger and does meet Brienne
again that would make for a good
resolution to that story well I'm
actually kind of hoping that they don't
meet again at least right away you know
I think eventually the characters that
are still alive into the story will
cross paths though there'll be a big war
for the dawn so either you're gonna die
or you're gonna be in that last big
battle if he does end up coming back
really what I'd like to see is him get
his own storyline by himself just like
try to do something good if you were to
run into Brienne again right away then
he'd probably revert to his pre trauma
persona
it's like Jaime Lannister running into
Cersei again who's on this redemptive
arc but it keeps backsliding
I think the same type of thing would
happen if the Hound ran into bran
too soon next question Travis asks what
do you think about the theory of mere
Reid being Jon Snow's twin sister so I
saw this on HuffPo which is already kind
of a red flag like you know huh
it's kind of a news aggregator they
don't really originate theories like
that I think it's a lot of fun but I do
think that it's nonsense Mir has mostly
been a part of bran storyline and
because the show is cut a lot of that
out so far just just hasn't done a lot
of brand scenes there isn't as much
context as there is in the books in the
books there's kind of like a ship
developing between bran and Mira like
bran develops feelings for Mira whether
or not she reciprocates remains to be
seen especially considering his current
condition but I feel like she's as
perfect as she's ever going to be it's
not going to turn into some neville
longbottom harry potter situation where
it's like you're the special one oh wait
no there's another person who could
totally be the special person I feel
like the person that originated this
theory is probably like a giant Harry
Potter fan but usually things that turn
me off to theories in the books like
make me feel like they're dead ends is
that their overly complicated and they
fly in the face of other theories that
have more evidence to their credit the
mira theory is really predicated on the
idea that there were two babies in the
Tower of joy in the most prominent
theory about two babies at the tower joy
is that Daenerys was born of Lyanna
stark and rhaegar targaryen but the
Daenerys Tower of joy theory is mostly
in opposition to the Jon Snow theory so
the most common belief based on what
George R Martin has presented in terms
of timelines and and when people say
that certain characters were born is
that there was one baby at the Tower of
joy Daenerys was conceived on the eve of
the Battle of the Trident John Snow was
born like 1 2 3 months after the Battle
of the Trident that would make her
several months younger than Jon Snow so
that's more of a strike against the
Daenerys Rhaegar Targaryen Lyanna stark
theory but the evidence that the HuffPo
article points to is a little bit silly
like one of their points is is it the
actress that plays Meera looks like Kit
Harington which is just ridiculous and
the theory itself that they're posting
is kind of late to the game like they
they're crediting a redditor but really
like if you go back even like 3 years I
think it's like 2012 or 2013
there's the exact same theory on the
Song of Ice and Fire forums so this is
really like an old theory that's already
kind of been disproven by the book
reading audience that the show audience
is just now getting to so it's just a
little too complicated relies on the
wrong kind of evidence and flies in the
face of
the theories that have more proof right
now taking both the show and the books
taking all the context is provided I
feel like as a character she works
better as a loyal friend and follower of
bran I do totally want to see her get
some crazy action it wins a winner and
dream of spring but I feel like that's
all going to be relegated to the brand
storyline she'll be too brand like
Brienne is supposed to be - Sansa only
she'll just be way better at her job
I mean brands awesome but she's been a
complete failure at her first task
finding and saving Sansa Stark but just
because I don't totally buy into the
theory doesn't mean that I don't think
that it's fun some of the best theories
in the world are just completely
ridiculous like Tyrion Jaime and Cersei
all being Targaryen so please keep
sending me all the crazy theories that
you guys hear about throw is fun to talk
about
just remember the reality of the actual
story is usually much more boring than
the stuff that the fandom comes up with
just ask Harry Potter fans next question
dawn asks why do people still think that
Stannis could be alive the HBO website
said that brand killed him the one true
king is dead time to bend the knee to
someone else now well I mean you know
people are just picking up on the fact
that they didn't see him die on screen
and it is a big TV trope that people
come back when you don't see them die
they're also playing on the fact that
George R Martin usually does not tell
people when a character is dead if they
haven't seen him in a while
Benjen stark is the best example that
any time people ask George R Martin
about that he's like I didn't say that
he's dead the thing that George R Martin
said though like he made a comment and
everyone was going crazy about it he
said in my books he is definitely still
alive but you have to remember that the
standard storyline of the books is
dramatically different than what
happened on the show some of the
storylines on the show follow the books
pretty closely some of them are wildly
wildly different Sansa is another good
example of a show character that's
dramatically different from her book
character right now and you have to
remember that we saw Barristan Selmy die
on the show he's still totally alive in
the books next question though anna-lena
asks just to be concerned about Tyrion
storyline that it'll turn out to be
rather dull in season six
now the HBO's announced there'll be no
shooting in Croatia which means no big
marine scenes except indoors
I'm afraid about Tyrion so you're saying
yeah like just because they're filming a
lot more in
our stuff there's not going to be any
like big action Tyrian scenes that he's
involved with it's totally possible that
could happen it sounds like that's
what's happening in King's Landing too
they're just they're filming a lot
indoors so it'll be a lot more close-up
personal drama than big crazy action
like most of the big crazy action
they're teasing will probably happen in
the North just because it seems like
Tyrion isn't getting any like crazy huge
scenes doesn't mean that there won't be
interesting storylines you have to
remember that Daenerys dragons are still
underneath the pyramid they haven't
gotten out yet
so Tyrion is gonna have to deal with
them and he's gonna have to solve the
problem of slavers Bay Daenerys has thus
far been unable to completely pacify
slavers Bay so Tyrion will probably just
be doing the things that he's best at
and hopefully he will start learning
more about dragons I really want him to
start studying like Sam was going to be
studying about White Walkers next
question Jason asks in a recent
interview George R Martin said there's
no absolute good and no absolute evil in
the world at Game of Thrones however
isn't the mountain completely evil or
the others you're talking about the
White Walkers yeah I mean no authors
going to come out and say yeah this
person is completely bad just because
that completely lops off any storyline
or any twist they might want to
introduce I think everybody would just
scream in rage if we never got any
storylines from the White Walkers
perspective the types of twists that you
see especially with TV shows is that you
meet someone that's presented as a
villain but then later you get the story
from their perspective and from their
perspective they're the protagonist of
the story really every character is the
hero of their own story that's true of
anything the problem on Game of Thrones
right now and even in the books is that
we haven't got that deep dive into White
Walkers yet thank you so much everyone
for submitting questions these are
always a ton of fun to do I feel like
we're still going to be talking about
this Jon Snow mirror read thing but most
of my stuff will be on like Twitter
Facebook I'll try to answer some more
questions in the comments but
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner northern XY you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to message me on the
back end of my channel so and get your
contact info I've already seen some good
suggestions for next week's bonus video
about like missing characters big
characters that we haven't seen in a
while
so I'll probably settle on the next
couple but bye next bonus video will
post on Sunday before fear the walking
dead if you're not cut up on that show
I'll put my Walking Dead playlist link
in the description so you guys can catch
up just in case you guys haven't seen it
I did
video all about the gravedigger theory
in the Hound maybe coming back you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here to learn all about the
enchanted horns the Horn of winter and
dragon binder thank you so much watching
everybody high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you